So here's the palette that Nick created
running in an actual Android app.
The first thing I did was
create a colors.xml file
containing the colors
that I wanted to specify.
For the names, I used what was listed
in the material design guidelines, so
indigo_300, indigo_500,
700, and pink_a200.
And the use the hexadecimal value for
those colors.
In the style for the app, I used those
identifiers, prefixed by @color,
and a slash for my color primary,
primary dark, and the accent color.
This makes it whole
lot more readable and
you only have to change colors in
one place, your colors.xml file.
In the xml for
our view, we can specify those
identifiers in a couple different ways.
So we can see here, we set our app
bar layout, that's the container
that holds our app bar, to have
a background with the primary color.
Now the reason we have
this question mark here
is that colorPrimary refers
to a theme local attribute.
We could have also listed
?attr/colorPrimary.
So if we look at
the floating action button
you might notice that there isn't any
designation of color information here.
That's because behind the scenes,
it assigns the color accent
value if you specified it.
So check out this link, which is also
specified in the instructors notes,
to see what other attributes you can
change and customize in material design.